[Music]
raiders coach john gruden continues to
love him some nathan peter and the guy
who flamed out in buffalo but a guy who
gruden is trying to turn into an nfl
quarterback who knows maybe the primary
backup derek carr maybe the eventual
successor to derek carr chris
you've been around john gruden i mean
look the guy's a great
coach he's a great offensive tactician
but his quarterback evaluation skills
leave something to be desired and as i
say that
it's like i'm setting up an insult of
you since you were drafted by john
gruden but you weren't really drafted by
john gruden you were drafted by rich
mckay and john gruden learned about you
after the fact i think he did i mean i
definitely do just to shed some light on
that yeah i don't think he wanted to
draft me and i don't think he even
studied me until he saw me throw some
lasers in practice and then all of a
sudden he called me in one day and he
was sitting there watching my texas film
and he's going how did you make that
throw what'd you do there how'd you do
that and i was like sitting there going
damn he really didn't want me he had no
freaking clue about anything he wanted
some other guys in the draft i'm not
even going to say their name who i
promised you i could have thrown better
with my other arm than they could have
but yeah hey gruden is an offensive
genius he really is he's a mastermind
that way now evaluating quarterbacks and
that as far as young guys especially
that's why he always wants veteran guys
i don't think he's very good at
evaluating young guys i'm sorry that's
just how i feel he's still awesome at
what he does and everything like that i
just hope he's not putting himself in a
corner of like still trying to justify
that he liked nathan peterman when he's
coming out in the draft and he still
just doesn't want to get off that
because of ego or i liked him then and i
he's this is dangerous this is dangerous
i know mike glennon's also looked very
good uh he really has i mean you saw the
game against arizona two weeks ago he
was throwing bombs all over the field
they went right down the field they
marched they scored touchdowns whatever
it was
when you you're dancing with the fine
line of nathan peterman if he gets in
there and throws a pick
okay in the first series he's in there
i'm telling you the whole team's gonna
go what the hell were we thinking we
knew what this guy did plus he always
talks about the guy not having any juice
and i'm just shocked that he loves a guy
that doesn't have any juice so that to
me is an interesting thing he keeps
talking up peter man i'm going to be
interested to see what he does when it's
all said and done here
i really do think that john gruden wants
to find another rich ganon a reclamation
project that he can take credit for and
and also the bottom line is whether it's
nathan peterman mike lennon or someone
else i think the real message here deep
down is that john gruden wants not derek
carr and i know that gets raiders fans
riled up because everybody's zero and
zero now and they want to be hopeful and
they don't want to be they don't want to
be disrupted in their in their you know
unbridled enthusiasm about the chances
their team has this year and talking
about getting rid of derrick carr does
that but i think that that's the end
game someone other than derek carr as
soon as 2020. i i don't know if i agree
with that i don't know i guess is what i
don't know is how john gruden could
really even evaluated derek carr last
year with kind of the crap that was
around him for lack of a better phrase i
mean it was tough it was one of the
worst old lines in football no receivers
running backs were below average i mean
nothing was there to help derek carr
last year he's certainly the most
talented of that group i can tell you
that i mean derek carr has some very
special physical attributes he's quick
release can throw the ball from
different angles i mean he was in the
mvp conversation a few years back to
where he's probably gonna win if he
doesn't break his leg against the colts
in that late you know week 14 or 15
matchup uh the year the raiders got into
the playoffs so there's certainly a
higher end ceiling there and he's got to
be patient with derek carr i hope he
hasn't made his mind up quite yet
i can imagine john gruden at 3 45
showing up at the office this week
popping in some andrew luck film trying
to come up with
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports